we have this big moment in the moment is
that fourth
years of my teaching career
i walked into the classroom
having no idea if the kids had done the
homework
or how
how
uh what their commitment was to
the subject and then suddenly
there's this coaching platform on khan
academy that
was a total game changer for me i
wasn't imagining
that the khan academy calculus content
would become
uh
a
what a big
part of our curriculum
i imagined frankly and wrongly
that we'd use these exercises suggest
kids use it for review
and it when we discovered the coaching
platform and how powerful that was
um a group of us
uh
said let's give it a go let's try using
khan academy
as a major part of our curriculum and
my goodness it changed the way i teach
for instance
five minutes before i walk into class i
can go to the platform and i can look
through my list of students to discover
that all the two of them
had done the homework had watched the
videos had cleared the
you know had cleared the hurdle if you
will of the exercises that i had given
them
so when i walked in the room
i didn't have to go over homework
anymore
that was liberating
um
and
so if there were two students who didn't
do the homework it gave me the
opportunity to pull them aside
and
say hey i see you didn't get to it or i
see you struggled with it
is there a way that uh that you and i
can meet later today it's because i
don't want you to get behind in this
and
the first 15 minutes of class now all of
a sudden we're breaking new ground we're
doing harder problems
and
uh
the kids
responded so well to it because i think
they had years and years and years
of math teachers going over the homework
for the first 15 minutes of class
and the poor kids must have been bored
to death
or
why bother doing the homework because
he'll do it on the board anyway so that
was just totally liberating um
and uh
gave me an opportunity to really
think hard
about teaching
since we started using khan academy the
one thing that
uh
we can't help but notice is that we're
having more kids
uh make it to the end of bc calculus and
it's clear to me that we're having
uh
more girls
and more underrepresented kids finish
our bc calculus class than we ever did
before
and
i gotta believe it's
our new way about thinking about
teaching and
using khan academy in the classroom and
for homework assignments has got to be a
big part of that